All right, so let's take a moment and
just explicitly talk about parameters in machine learning.
And parameters are arguments that you pass when you create your classifier.
So this is before fitting, and they can make
a huge difference in the decision boundary that your algorithm arrives at.
So what are some of the parameters for an SVM?
Well, we've talked about one already, which is the kernel, and there
are two more that we're going to talk about right now, which are C and γ.
And that was the difference between these two SVMs that I
showed you just a minute ago, is they had different kernels, so the one on
the left was a linear kernel and the one on the right was an rbf kernel.
And as it happened, I was also monkeying around with γ here.
If you don't monkey around with γ,
they'll actually look much more similar than this.
So the γ in this case happened to be a 1,000.
So here's a quiz for you, a reason for you to try some stuff on your own.
Which of the following SVMs do you get when you use the parameters,
kernel is a linear kernel and the γ is set to 1.0?
So remember before, it was 1000, so
now we're bringing down our γ by three orders of magnitude.
Let me give you a few options.
Which one do you think is the linear kernel with a γ of 1.0?